[Music]
milk does the body good
that's gross oh sure green milk grosses
you all out but no one had any
complaints back when I was drinking blue
milk
hello Internet
welcome to film theory where nothing in
this entire vast universe can stop me
from trying to correctly predict
something anything about Star Wars
that's right folks today I will pay my
respects to the age-old belief that if
you fail at something you should try try
again even if it threatens to turn you
into the Jar Jar Binks of Star Wars
theories I mean I've been wrong about
Star Wars so many times that even me
joking about being wrong about Star Wars
is an opening that I've already used in
a previous Star Wars video a video where
surprise surprise I end up being wrong
yet again but in the words of someone
important I forget exactly who let the
past die kill it if you have to and so I
have I've killed it burying it in the
middle of the Arizona desert burned off
my fingerprints to make sure nothing has
ever traced back to me
and so I'm back to the scene of the
crime with a solid idea of what's gonna
happen in the other major blockbuster
finale we have coming out later this
year Star Wars Episode nine rise of
Skywalker it's a solid theory based on
canon lore solid narrative beats seated
into past movies even some necessary
business decisions on the part of Disney
then again we've seen how much the last
movie cared about all that stuff Brad
today's theory all starts with one thing
the laugh that lit the internet on fire
nope that's not penny wise at the end of
the episode 9 trailer we get ourselves
the iconic laugh of our old pal sheave
sheev Palpatine the evil emperor himself
raisin face I mean what is this guy
doing back outside a very clearly trying
to win back fans be a nostalgia prompt
analysis videos like this one asking
that very question and also fill in the
obvious caping villain role that these
movies now have after
[Music]
outside of small reasons like that from
a narrative standpoint what is she doing
back here last we saw the Emperor he was
well kinda deader than a mannequin being
thrown off of a catwalk and exploding
into an energy core
why how I have so many questions and
that is what our theory is today
predicting the role that Emperor
Palpatine will play in the upcoming
finale to the Star Wars and enology you
don't hear too frequently people talking
about nine part series as an analogy but
that's technically the correct term
ladies and gentlemen it is my belief
that sheev Palpatine aka Darth Sidious
aka Dark Lord of the Sith himself
created Rey that Rey is a part of an
elaborate plot by the Emperor to live on
even in the face of death sounds extreme
right I know it is that's why it's so
exciting because it sounds so stupidly
absurd and yet you know that I wouldn't
be claiming this in an episode of this
show if I didn't have any evidence to
back it up I feel the conflict in you
yeah taemi partly job so no more
conflict friends let me show you what I
got see if I can draw you over to my
side of the force first let's take a
look at sheave himself in Revenge of the
Sith
Palpatine tells a young anakin skywalker
about the tragedy of Darth Plagueis the
wise according to Palpatine Darth
Plagueis was a Dark Lord of the Sith so
powerful and so wise he could use the
Force to influence the midi-chlorians to
create a quick note here with the
release of the new Star Wars movies many
people have called into question
controversial additions to the universe
that were made during the prequels
including most famously the
midi-chlorians
what are midi-chlorians it is lorian's
are a microscopic life-form that resides
within all living cells they continually
speak to us telling us the will of the
force are these things still canon I
mean so many Star Wars fans want them to
not be the official answer is yeah yeah
they absolutely are the rule of thumb
here is that if it appears in the movies
or if it appears in a few select books
that were published after 2015 it is
still canon and if we're talking about
questionable canonicity I mean heck in
the last Jedi Luke uses a doppelganger
technique to trick kylo Ren when fans
jumped at the fact that this seemed like
a brand-new Jedi trick coming out of
nowhere writer and director Rian Johnson
took to Twitter to prove that it was in
the Jedi path a manual for students of
the force a 2010 book that wasn't
considered canon by Mo's but dry and
Johnson it was fair game so basically
what is and isn't canon in this
franchise can best be summarized like
this Shaw will figure it out that's not
how the force works oh yeah
Darth Plagueis was a Dark Lord of the
Sith so powerful and so wise he could
use the Force to influence the
midi-chlorians to create so we know that
somewhere out there extreme sensitivity
to the force allows for control over
life itself so who is Darth Plagueis
well it doesn't matter cuz he's dead son
unfortunately he taught his apprentice
everything he knew then his apprentice
killed him in his sleep when Anakin asks
if it's possible to learn the power to
create life and keep people from dying
help a teen tells him yes but not from a
Jedi
what Palpatine doesn't tell Anakin at
the time is that Darth Plagueis is
apprentice Darth Sidious is none other
than Emperor Palpatine himself and now
we're getting somewhere
because this tells us that Palpatine
does indeed have the power to create
life using the force or at the very
least has knowledge that the force can
be used to manipulate life-forms in some
way but what cause would he have to do
something like that well though we don't
hear a lot about this in the films it's
been very well established through
supplemental canonical materials like
shattered Empire aftermath novels in the
last Jedi expanded edition that Emperor
Palpatine made numerous contingency
orders in the event of his early and
untimely death and when I say numerous
contingency plans I don't mean one I
don't mean two or even ten I am talking
150 I guess it's best to be
over-prepared as he himself says in the
novel aftermath quote if an empire sorry
it just kind of sounds wrong in my usual
voice I try this again
frog voice as I say in the novel
aftermath if an empire cannot protect
its Emperor then that Empire must be
deemed a failure it collapses not only
because it's central figure is gone but
because it must not be allowed to remain
in short these contingency plans were
meant to be a final screw you to
everyone who had a hand in his death but
like the most extreme screw you possible
since you know the entailed mass death
at a galactic scale a giant
self-destruct plan that eradicate the
rebels while also cutting out most of
his former Empire eliminating all the
weakness within it so that its strongest
elements live on and rebuild to be
stronger than before
I've actually talked in depth about one
of these particular plans overrun game
theory operation cinder which was the
contingency plan featured prominently in
Star Wars Battlefront 2 again a
canonical source of lore where
satellites were used to permanently
change the climates of planets into
hostile deadly storms okay so we've
established that Palpatine has control
over life and has a bunch of plans laid
out for his untimely death it's also
probably worth noting here that one
element of his contingency plan directly
resulted in the creation of the first
order yeah I'm sure he wasn't the only
one wondering where these guys came from
at the beginning of Star Wars Episode
seven you go from Episode six with happy
dancing teddy bears and another Death
Star explosion given a final kick in the
balls to the Empire and then suddenly
the force awakens starts where it's like
oh yeah there are these other new guys
now I mean I was in the theater being
like what
where do they come from I'm sorry all
we're given is that Luke leaves and
suddenly the rebellion is like whoops we
happen to let in the space Nazis
oh yeah and PS they also have a bigger
death ball dear rebellion here's some
real talk for you if one space magician
takes a vacation and he can't detect a
giant planet of death sneaking in under
your noses maybe you shouldn't be the
ones in charge of things oh and by the
way you one minute text scroll in front
of the movies setting up everything that
I'm supposed to know about sorry
that's not enough information for me
anyway rant aside the first order was
born in a pretty complicated way but
born nonetheless from Palpatine's
contingency plans true to his plan the
weak parts of the Empire were cold away
those who remained retreated into the
unknown regions of space aboard Emperor
Palpatine s mega ship the Eclipse they
came back stronger they came back as the
first order as it said in the book quote
it's time to start over that is our
first order to begin again and to get it
right this time see there it is first
order so we have ourselves contingency
plans force driven life control and a
connection to the events that we see
playing out in the movies but what does
any of this have to do with the REA and
rise of the Skywalker cuz yeah I
remember that that was the thesis I
started this entire episode out with
well buckle up friends because it's time
we talk about the jakku observatory yeah
the very same Jack who where Rey was
left and grew up on the jakku
observatory was part of a network of
observatories across the galaxy built by
none other than Emperor Palpatine
himself as part of those death
contingency plans not all that much is
said about the jakku observatory but we
do know some crucial details about it
one that it housed ancient Sith relics
too that in building it he had to bore
down to the center of the planet and
three that Palpatine outright says he
considers jakku very important to his
plans to quote from the book Hal Pettine
told him that once the world was verdant
overgrown with green and home to oceans
he said that though the surface of the
world
shows it the course still has that vital
spark of life essence are you ready
racks asked Palpatine's old advisor
I am Palpatine lives on we will find him
again out there in the dark
everything has arranged itself as our
master foretold so we have ourselves a
mysterious station that houses powerful
ancient force relics built by the
Emperor who is paranoid about dying
which drills down to the core of a
planet that were explicitly told has
untapped life essence and all of this is
happening on Ray's whole planet a planet
where mind you he has no memories of her
parents or her childhood a desert planet
that according to the Star Wars Episode
nine trailer we're gonna be revisiting
in this latest movie that doesn't get
your midi-chlorians and a twist I don't
know what will
so we've got ourselves a motive a method
and a location
all of which coming from Palpatine side
but what about ray herself have there
been any clues to this being her
possible origin in the movies well yeah
actually there's been plenty of evidence
toward that we've certainly seen signs
of a possible Dark Side connection from
Earth and it all begins here the mirror
cave from the last Jedi when she first
begins our training with Luke in the
last Jedi she's immediately drawn to
this mysterious tunnel underground which
symbolically leads directly to darkness
there's something else in Ethier 'ln the
place top thanks balance powerful light
powerful darkness it's cooling that's
not all ray gives into it even after
being warned against it by Luke she
descends into the cave to find her
parents it's a clear parallel to Luke's
trip into the cave and Dagobah during
his training but instead of being
fearful of what she sees inside like
Luke is ray is calm and she herself says
I should have felt trapped or panicked I
didn't I knew it was leading somewhere
but here's the biggest kicker when Rey
asks to see her parents she sees two
figures morph into one and then a
reflection of herself appears it's odd
it's like the cave is playing a prank on
her despite her being comfortable in
this place and seemingly mastered its
use she
is up not getting the answers that she
wanted out of this thing I mean this
cave is either the world's biggest jerk
or it actually did answer the questions
she asked consider this maybe it doesn't
show her parents because she has maybe
it shows her two figures merging into
one because she only does have one
parent Palpatine which is then revealed
to be herself because that's all there
is
there's Palpatine and then her she's a
clone of Palpatine or a little girl who
was manipulated by Palpatine or whatever
symbolism and explanation you want take
your pick
I'm not exactly sure what she is just
that she was created or manipulated in
some way by Palpatine as a revenge plot
and lastly let's think about what this
would mean for the story first it would
address one of the biggest mysteries of
these last three movies in a satisfying
new way instead of Rey's parentage
literally being a throwaway plot thread
something used to string us along or
make some wider point about not being
special it suddenly would have a payoff
established and believable within the
existing lore clones and force
manipulation are canonical things that
every casual fan of the series knows no
need to have Mary Poppins flying through
space this time and after the
controversial reception of the last
movie and then solo after its - our wars
need something huge that's gonna be
well-liked by pretty much all audiences
who go to see this thing it's also
pretty easy to retcon this into the
story as it's going I mean sure kylo Ren
in the last Jedi tells Rey that her
parents are nobodies but how would he
know the emperor's plot how could he
know the emperor's plot he especially
wouldn't know about the Emperor's secret
plan because this was Palpatine's last
big secret Jeeves contingency plans
brought back his empire through the
first order and now the highly force
sensitive girl with questionable
parentage that just so happens to be on
the planet where he has a weird
laboratory is starting to get lured away
by the dark side I don't know about you
but that certainly feels like a viable
candidate for Palpatine's replacement
thematically it works well too it makes
all 9 movies in this franchise about the
Skywalker's and the Palpatine's our
heroes and our villains the prequels are
all about Anakin Skywalker growing up
under the guidance of Darth Sidious a
corrupting force fed
have the original trilogy all about the
Skywalker's both Anakin and Luke dealing
with Palpatine and his Emperor at the
height of its power and now this new
trilogy is about the new wave of
Skywalker Luke passing it on to kylo Ren
who remember is Leia son a Skywalker
even if she's never really called that
dealing with Palpatine from beyond the
grave in the form of Rey there's also
that good old George Lucas quote that we
mentioned all the time and get a
portrait they rhyme well Rey being
connected Palpatine actually sets up the
potential for a rhyming story with kylo
Ren the character that we've seen as
Rey's counterpart through these movies
he's a villain sort of but at the end of
force awakens we see him flirt with
being good in the last Jedi that
struggle continues meanwhile we have
ourselves Rey who's been flirting with
the darkness she's exposed to it more
and more
so if kylo were to emerge from the
darkness and Ray were to descend into it
BAM classic Star Wars counterpoint
parallelism it's poetic it's satisfying
and darn it what a great twist for the
girl to be the main villain and most
importantly if this theory were to be
true it steeped in enough grounded lore
and established characterization that
fans won't have petitions to remake the
whole darn thing I've made strong cases
for theories that would have reflected
excellent storytelling in the past and
been wrong before but you know what it's
fine I'm not bitter much so there you
have it theorists Rey was created by
Palpatine or his loyal followers in the
event of his death on jakku at the Jack
who Observatory that's why we hear his
laugh and why by the end of rise of
Skywalker he'll have gone complete
villain explains Rey's natural talents
with the force her inclination towards
the dark side and Palpatine's return in
the upcoming film all while being super
poetic and emphasizing the classic Star
Wars themes about the struggles between
good
evil and let's just face it it's a great
twist to have this girl who's been set
up as our hero be the ultimate villain
all along but hey that's just a theory a
film theory and cut then that Empire
must be deemed Oh need a glass of water
after that voice wasn't even close I
don't even know why I try why did I
choose to write that in the script like
here let me write in an opportunity for
me to show the internet how much I suck
at impressions at least it's different
sounding voice I guess frog voice